Die Ligatur zu Europa ist wieder da.
Wir sprechen heute über Mallorca, die Roma, Bologna, Lille und die Premier League.
Und all das waren noch nicht mal alle Themen. Ach, es ist einfach ein schönes Format. Schön, dass ihr da seid und schön, dass Alex Treuker, Michael Postel, Christian Bernhardt und später noch Uli Hebel hier sind. Jetzt geht's los!
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Immer noch ein fantastisches Intro und niemand von euch da draußen hat gemerkt, dass ich es gekürzt habe. Seht ihr? So gut kann man kürzen. Muss ich mich jetzt einfach mal selber loben. Der große Aufschrei, er ist ausgeblieben, obwohl ihn einige angekündigt haben. Geh nicht ans Intro ran. Ich hab's gemacht. Keiner hat's gemerkt. So. Naja, also schön, dass wir hier sind. Was war das für ein komischer Einstieg? Ich weiß es doch auch nicht. Aber schön, dass wir die Ligatur aufnehmen. Wir haben viele, viele Themen. Champions League ist diesmal gar nicht mit dabei. Fand ich ganz interessant. Alex, möchtest du aus spanischer Sicht nicht über Real gegen Leipzig reden? Kickt dich nicht?
Ich habe den Ersatztorwart von Mallorca nominiert. Also es wird ein bisschen eine kleine Mallorca-Folge, merkt man schon. Aber warum ist er anfangs hier? Also es passt wahrscheinlich nicht besser, dieser kleine Award, als auf den Ersatzkeeper von Mallorca, der in La Liga ja gar nicht spielt. Denn da ist er ja die Nummer 2, aber man kennt das Modell ja von vielen Vereinen. Vor allem in Spanien ist es Tradition, dass im Pokal der zweite Mann ran darf. Und er hat in der regulären Spielzeit einen Elfmeter gehalten in San Sebastian von Bryce Mendez und hat dann von Miquel Oya-Sabal im Elfmeterschießen den ersten Elfmeter gehalten – zwei Elfmeter in einem Spiel. Also der Finaleinzug, der geht hauptsächlich auf seine Kappe und deswegen der Anzang Hero von mir, um es mal kürzer zu machen. Denn, wie gesagt, er spielt ja nicht viel, also man kann ja nicht viel über ihn sagen. Dominik Greif, Slowene ist er, glaube ich, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Und ja, selten im Mittelpunkt, aber in dem Halbfinale war mal ein entscheidender Mann im Mittelpunkt eben.
Aber ist er jetzt Anzang Hero oder ist er MVP?
Beides für mich. Anzang Hero. MVP hast du ja vorhin ein bisschen gespoilert. Anzang Hero.
Ich sehe schon. Ich muss hier meine Notizen minütlich quasi aktualisieren. Jetzt bin ich gespannt, was ich bei dir machen darf. Christian, wie heißt die? Sebastian.
Entwirre mal die Verwirrung, Christian.
Soll ich einfach mal? Ich nehme einfach mal MVP. Ja, also ich finde, da führt kein Weg dran vorbei. Wir haben jetzt nicht über Inter geredet, das haben wir ja schon, aber was Inter gerade abliefert, ist ganz, ganz großes Kino und da landen wir ja unweigerlich bei Simone Insagi. Also was Insagi mit dieser Mannschaft gemacht hat oder immer noch macht, ist herausragend. Also wir haben viel über Inter ja oft geredet, die letzten Jahre defensive Stabilität, aber was Insagi mit dieser Mannschaft jetzt auch offensiv entwickelt hat, das ist unglaublich. Sie haben jetzt am Montag gegen Genua 2-1 gewonnen, aber in den vier Spielen davor in der Liga jeweils vier Tore erzielt. Also das ist Inter im Moment eine Maschine. Und warum ich Insagi da unbedingt nehmen wollte, es funktionieren jetzt auch die, die nicht immer spielen. Es gab zuletzt, hat dreimal Cialanolo gefehlt, die Rolle von Cialanolo haben wir ja auch schon thematisiert. Jetzt hat Christian Aslani für ihn gespielt. Das ist der kleine Bruder von Cialanolo, so nennt er ihn, kümmert sich immer um ihn, hat auch schon vor Wochen gesagt, werdet sehen, Aslani ist auf einem super Weg. Aslani hat jetzt gegen Genoa getroffen, hat in den zwei Spielen davor die Fäden im Zentrum gezogen als Regisseur. Und wenn dann, finde ich, solche Spieler, die oft in der zweiten Reihe sind, wie Aslani Sanchez funktioniert, de Vrij spielt gerade für Acerbi, dann landet man unweigerlich beim Trainer, weil er im Moment nicht nur die Top 11, 12, 13 sozusagen auf dieses Niveau gehoben hat, sondern wirklich die komplett. Also alle Spieler unter uns Sagi entwickeln sich im Moment weiter oder sind auf einem anderen Niveau. Und dementsprechend, das heißt, aus Italien hat man jetzt vernommen, dass er auch auf der Liste von Liverpool sein soll. Aber es heißt, dass er sich unfassbar wohlfühlt in Mailand, der wird, glaube ich, auch in Kürze verlängern. Also in Sagi und Inter im Moment einfach nur ganz großes Kino. 15 Punkte Vorsprung auf Juve, 13 Gegentore erst nach 27 Spielen mit 69 Toren. Der beste Angriff der Liga. Es ist aktuell noch nach Leverkusen, weil die nur nicht verloren haben in allen Pflichtspielen. Aber auf jeden Fall das weit heißeste Team Europas, kann man eigentlich schon sagen. Also das ist vorne wie hinten. Ja, und wir haben vorhin wenig über die Champions League gesprochen. Klar, die haben jetzt das schwierige Rückspiel bei Atletico. Aber ich würde sagen, wenn sie da weiterkommen. Also Inter im Moment, weil sie auch diese Wettkampfherde in K.o. spielen haben. Das haben sie letztes Jahr schon gezeigt. Da ist ja Insagi auch ein Experte, quasi dieses 180 Minuten Hin- und Rückspiel. Und jetzt haben sie einfach noch mehr viel Selbstsicherheit aus diesem letztjährigen, zwar verlorenen Champions League-Final, aber die Art und Weise, wie sie City die Stirn geboten haben, das haben sie perfekt weiter transportiert und haben sich offensiv unfassbar weiterentwickelt. Schaut euch mal an, ja sie spielen mit Dreierkette, aber schaut euch mal an, wo Pavar und Bastoni in Ballbesitz spielen. Also die Abläufe von Insagi sind im Moment herausragend. Und sie können das auch irgendwie verkraften, dass ja ein Sommer so klein ist. Anscheinend, ja. Geht sogar das. Also dann ist er auch mein MVP, wenn Simone Insagi sogar das hinbekommt. Absolut fantastisch. Also inter, wirklich schaut euch das nochmal genauer an und immer die ganzen Storylines, die ja auch zum Teil aus der Bundesliga kommen. Pavard und Sommer und so weiter. Es ist sehr, sehr faszinierend. Faszinierend ist auch, dass ich jetzt gar nicht mehr weiß, welche Awards jetzt noch bei dir offen sind, Michael. Da musst du mir jetzt helfen. Also Jonathan Klaus hast du mir jetzt MVP gesagt. Bleibt das so? Wer ist dein Anzang Hero?
Ähm, ja, nehmen wir ihn doch als Anzang Hero deshalb, weil er ja in Ungnade gefallen war im Winter. Aber jetzt doch vorgeschnellt ist auf dem Platz. Dann nehmen wir doch, weil Valiable, also Most Valiable Player würde passen auf die Ligue 1 selber, weil die natürlich jetzt gerade in Verhandlungen sind wegen der Namensrechte für ihre Liga. Die vergeben sie im nächsten Jahr wahrscheinlich neu, weil McDonald's bereit ist, 20 Millionen zu zahlen pro Saison. Aktuell ist es noch Uber Eats, die zahlen 16 Millionen. Also ein deutlicher Sprung nochmal. Uber Eats war offenbar auch bereit, mehr zu zahlen, aber McDonald's hat dann auch nochmal aufgestockt. Also die wollen unbedingt diese Namensrechte. Und ja, das dann ein bisschen zu einer skurrilen Liga-Benennung führen würde. Aber gut, Uber Eats ist ja auch schon, ja.
Ehrlich gesagt wusste ich es gar nicht bis zu den Verhandlungen, dass dieser Sponsor gerade Sponsor der Liga ist. Das ist gut an mir vorbeigeflogen.
Ja, die treten halt vor allem im Wappen in Erscheinung. Also so groß in der Werbung werden jetzt nicht aufgezogen. Aber du kennst sie. Also es ist alles unterbewusst, Max. Deswegen wird es bei McDonald's genauso sein. Und ja, die hatten schon für die Live-Wetten, hatten sie schon mit Infront einen riesen Deal geschlossen. Ich glaube, über fast 160 Millionen oder was. Also die hätten, obwohl man muss sagen, also die Liga hätte wahrscheinlich gerne unsere Probleme mit irgendwelchen Tennisbällen, weil die haben halt dann die Probleme mit Glaswaschen oder was, die dann geworfen werden. Das ist eine andere Geschichte. Aber die haben halt ihren Sponsor und verhandeln jetzt munter weiter. Und es läuft alles auf, oder es deutet sehr viel gerade auf McDonald's hin. Mit 20 Millionen pro Jahr ist dann die Liga für mich der MVP.
Also ist das auch ein guter Deal, weil ich habe mich gefragt, naja, 20 Millionen, das sind ja ein bisschen mehr als eine Million, wenn man die jetzt gleich verteilen würde an alle Ligateilnehmer.
Naja, es ist ein besserer Deal als bisher. Also insofern ist es schon ein guter Deal. Aber natürlich ist es kein Vergleich. Man muss auch sagen, die Liga A ist immer noch ein bisschen unter dem Radar, was das Interesse in anderen Ländern angeht. Also da ist Deutschland deutlich weiter und kann dementsprechend auch mehr verlangen. Sie nennen sich auch selber die Liga de Talente, also es ist schon noch ein Schritt bis zu einer großen Liga, die auch deutlich mehr verlangen kann.
Okay, die ganze Liga als MVP. Alex, bei dir, wer ist dein MVP?
Er war ja Greif, ich habe es selber noch mal im Kopf sortiert und hier auf meinem Zettel, den ich dir vorher abgeschickt hatte. Also Ansan Hiro ist jetzt bei ihm, Mallorca-Coach Javier Aguirre. Jetzt darfst du vorbeten, wo er überall war.
Ah, habe ich das noch offen, das muss ich mal gucken. Man sieht mich hier sehr schnell rumklicken. Ich habe es natürlich nicht mehr offen. Hast du es? Er war in Mexiko, Japan, war bei Atletico, hat bei verschiedenen spanischen Teams Stationen gemacht. Zwischendurch war er bei Teams, wo ich mir nicht sicher war, ob wir jetzt in Portugal oder in Spanien sind. Ich vermute, wir waren in Spanien in der 2. Liga.
Ich habe es auch nicht offen, weil ich dachte, du liest das vor. Ich wollte es ja vorher nicht abwürgen, aber ich habe es ja gemacht. Das ist ja einfach eine gut geölte Maschine, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Also auf jeden Fall Ansan Hiro. Warum? Na ja, logisch. Er zieht mit ihnen. Also er hält jedes Jahr die Klasse. Auch das, ich hatte es ja schon angekündigt, ich hatte Ihnen so nicht zugetraut. Sie werden auch dieses Jahr, glaube ich, die Klasse halten. Zumindest haben Sie die Widerstandsfähigkeit dafür. Also er wurde ja damals, glaube ich, unter der Saison vor jetzt 2 Jahren, eineinhalb Jahren wirklich nur als Retter geholt, als Feuerwehrmann. Und weil er ja 15 Stationen davor hatte und ich glaube, seit 30 Jahren Trainer ist, dachte ich mir auch, wow, das ist jetzt nicht so die inspirierende Wahl, die mir jetzt so viel Hoffnung macht, aber nee, hält die Klasse. Also er hat da eh schon aus meiner Sicht überperformt. Und wenn er sie jetzt ins Pokalfinale führt und er schlägt Girona, er knüpft Barca Punkte ab, hoffentlich nicht am Freitag, aber eben im Hinspiel, in der Hinrunde. Also er ärgert auch immer wieder die Großen. Mallorca spielt eine tolle Saison aus mit dem Pokalfinale. Das ist einfach eine historische Chance, dass sie mal wieder den Titel gewinnen können. Und deswegen ist der Coach der tolle Arbeit leistet.
Sehr, sehr gut. Ich habe es jetzt natürlich offen. Monterey, Leganes, Ägypten, Alvada, Japan, Espanol, Barcelona, Real Saragossa, Mexiko, Atletico, Osasuna, Mexiko, Pachuca und Atlante. Das waren seine Stationen. Ja, ehrlich gesagt bei keinem von beiden. Ich habe vorhin nur so quer gelesen, wie ich diese Station genannt habe. Es sind hier sehr viele Etapps. Christian kann es bezeugen. Was soll ich machen, wenn ihr zwischendurch ständig eure Kategorien wechselt? Bei dir habe ich mir gar nichts aufgeschrieben, Christian. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es mir nicht geschickt hast. Dann kommt jetzt die kleine Überraschung. Ich habe mich für Stanislav Filovotka entschieden. Wir schauen kurz nach Neapel. Da war ja auch vieles los. Marius ist zuletzt darüber geredet. Napoli hat in der vergangenen Woche erst das Volo 6-1 vom Platz gefakt und jetzt am Wochenende gegen Juve gewonnen. Das ist das wichtigste Spiel des Jahres. Die Szenen im Stadion waren sehr schön. Für beide oder nur für Neapel? Für Neapel auf jeden Fall. Für Juve gibt es viele andere. Klar, da ist mit Inter das Größere. Aber hatten wir schon die Geschichte des Süden, der sich versucht, gegen den wirtschaftsstarken Norden aufzulehnen. Da ist Juve einfach das Symbol in Neapel. Es gab wunderschöne Szenen am Wochenende. Aurelio de Laurentiis ist sitzend gehüpft. Das kann man sich vielleicht nicht vorstellen. Es gab ein wunderbares Bild, weil das ganze Stadion gesprungen ist. Sehr schön. Worauf ich hinauswollte, die Herren Ossimen und Quaratzkelia machen wieder das, was sie in der letzten Saison sehr regelmäßig gemacht haben. Sie haben in den zwei Spielen zusammen sechs Buden gemacht. Ossimen 3, Quaratzkelia 3. Dementsprechend ist der Fokus wieder sehr auf sie. Aber ich habe mir Lobotka rausgegriffen, weil Napoli in dieser Saison drei Trainer, Systemumstellungen gerade zuletzt unter Mazzari auf Fünferkette abwartend agieren, also nicht das, was die Mannschaft eigentlich ausmacht. Und der, der am meisten der Runden gelittern hat, war Lobotka, weil das Spiel so ein bisschen an ihm vorbei ging. Zuerst schon bei Garcia, der sehr viel vertikal gespielt hat, und jetzt unter Mazzari dann, weil es da mehr um das Spiel gegen den Ball ging. Und Calzona, der neue Trainer jetzt, der Lobotka eben aus der Slowakischen Nationalmannschaft kennt. Die beiden haben da zusammen sozusagen auch die Quali zur EM geschafft. Und Calzona hat sofort verstanden, dass Lobotka wieder das zentrale Element dieser Mannschaft sein muss. Und dementsprechend, ja, es wird wieder viel über Kwaratzkele und Osemen geredet, aber den Aufschwung, den Napoli jetzt so langsam nimmt, der liegt auch daran, dass Lobotka wieder viel zentraler ist, viel mehr Ballkontakt, der viel präsenter ist. Das tut Anguissa auch wunderbar gut. Also Lobotka plus Anguissa waren jetzt auch wirklich viel, viel stärker als in den Wochen davor. Und deshalb der Ansang Hero. Absolut perfekt. Dafür ist diese Kategorie da. Dann springen wir noch ein letztes Mal in die Liga. Michael, was ist dein Moment der letzten Wochen gewesen?
Ich glaube, das war der Moment, als Kian Mbappé ausgewechselt wurde und nicht auf die Bank gegangen ist, sondern auf die Tribüne sich neben seine Beraterin und Mutter gesetzt hat. Er steht also einfach auf Symbolik anscheinend.
In welchem Spiel war das? Also war das bevor oder nachdem er bei McRaw gegessen hat mit El Khali-Ee-Fee?
Ich glaube, das war davor. Ich meine, das war Rennen. Lass mich lügen. Auf jeden Fall ist er zur Halbzeit ausgewechselt worden. Er verhält sich ja schon immer mal wieder wie so ein Wandel der Scheidungsgründe. Deswegen hat er sich auf die Tribüne gesetzt, so weit wie möglich vom Trainer und von seinen Kollegen weg. Diese Symbolik hat man natürlich auch aufgegriffen. Es geht darum, um die Distanz, die zwischen ihm und dem Coach ist. Danach haben sie beide wieder versucht, die Wogen zu glätten. Luis Enrique hat dann gesagt, er muss sich auf die Zeit vorbereiten, wenn Mbappé dann endlich weg ist. Und Mbappé ist ohnehin sehr diplomatisch unterwegs, zumindest in der Öffentlichkeit. Zumindest das, was er sagt auch. Aber an gewollter Symbolik nicht zu übertreffen, im Moment meiner Ansicht nach.
Das war im Auswärtsspiel bei Monaco gegen Adi Högl.
Entschuldigen Sie.
Mbappé in die Knie gezogen, so wie wir das alle auf unserer Bingo-Karte hatten. Vor dieser Saison. Aber das war ja, glaube ich, nicht alles, was an Mbappé jetzt bemerkenswert war. Du hast mir geschrieben, erst beleidigt, dann beeindruckend. Was war denn dann das Beeindruckende? Reden wir jetzt über die Champions League?
Wir reden jetzt über die Champions League, genau. Er lässt sich halt anscheinend nicht davon leiten. Er wurde ausgewechselt, alle haben spekuliert. Ja, darf er dann in der Champions League wenigstens spielen. Er hat gespielt, er hat getroffen. Zwei Tore hat das Spiel eigentlich entschieden mit zwei Weltklasseaktionen. Also er lässt es alles dann, so viel ihm anscheinend egal ist, oder nicht egal ist, zum Beispiel, ob er jetzt Kapitän sein darf. Er durfte übrigens Kapitän sein, aber nur weil Marquinhos gefehlt hat. Wie viel Einfluss er jetzt im Verein hat, das ist ihm alles nicht egal. Aber dann ist es ihm wiederum egal, wie viel Trubel um seine Person eigentlich ist. Er kommt dann auf den Platz, macht halt diese zwei Tore. PSG kommt völlig locker weiter. Es zeichnet schon große Spieler aus, dass er sich von so etwas dann nicht leiten lässt. Also ich persönlich mag ihn jetzt nicht, aber das ist einfach stark. Nach so einem Gerede, nach diesem Wechsel, der verkündet wurde, obwohl er einen ganz anderen Kommunikationsplan hatte. Er wollte das eigentlich anders, uns vor allem selber verkünden, dass es dann durch die Siegheit im Klub ging. Das hat er den Verantwortlichen auch übel genommen. Und ja, dann gab es dann auch immer mal wieder Schwächephasen, muss man sagen, in der Liga, aber dann in der Champions League hat er geliefert. Und das ist schon beeindruckend für mich, ja genau.
Da war er da, hat im Grunde Real Sociedad allein ein bisschen aus dem Wettbewerb genommen. Das haben wir ja vorhin schon angesprochen. Was die Frage aufwirft, Alex, was ist dein Mallorca-Moment des Spieltags? Nein, da hast du jetzt mal was anderes gewählt.
Da habe ich was anderes. Das Moment des Spieltags ist leider ein sehr unschöner, ein sehr bitterer. Die Horrorverletzung von Diakabi, vom Valencia, dem Verteidiger im Liga-Spiel gegen Real Madrid, hat ja wirklich diesen Spieltag leider im Negativen sehr, sehr überschattet. So viel Positives ist auch gar nicht passiert, also ich jetzt am liebsten auch nicht erwähnt, aber es ist einfach die bittere, unschöne, hässliche Geschichte dieses Spieltags. Seine ganz, ganz schlimme Verletzung, Totalschaden im Knie, so kann man es, glaube ich, zusammenfassen. Ich glaube, er wird heute am Donnerstag operiert, dann weiß man genau, was alles gemacht wurde und was alles kaputt ist, aber das ganze Knie soll offenbar hinüber sein. Und zwar so schlimm, dass er bei positivem Heilungsverlauf, heißt es zumindest vorab, vor der OP, 9 bis 12 Monate ausfällt. Bei positiven Heilungsverlauf. Bei weniger positiven droht ihm sogar das Karriereende, weil eben das komplette Bein, das komplette Knie hinüber ist. Also er muss erst mal wieder schauen, dass er überhaupt, ja, dass der Fuß, das Knie vernünftig funktioniert, dass er normal laufen können wird in vielen, vielen Monaten. Und erst dann ist überhaupt daran zu denken, ob er wieder Fußball spielen können wird. Die AKB ist 27 Jahre jung, also ganz, ganz schlimme, bittere Geschichte. Und deswegen leider ein sehr unschöner Moment des Spieltags bei mir.
War das denn im Zuge eines Vs? Weil ich hatte von der Verletzung gelesen, ich hatte aber auch gelesen, wenn ihr ein Video davon seht, schaut es euch nicht an.
Ich habe es mir… Ich habe mich auch daran gehalten. Deswegen werde ich es nicht in Detail wiedergeben können, aber auch wollen. Zusammenprallen mit Juamini irgendwie verheddert, halb im Rasen, halb im Gegenspieler und dann, ja, sei es drum. Also ganz, ganz bitter, ne?
Und das aber halt auch so interessant, weil die Geschichte, die von diesem Spiel geblieben ist, war der verfrühte Schlusspfiff, mit dem Real Madrid mutmaßlich der Sieg nach Aufruhrjagd genommen wurde. Und diese Verletzung war aber dann so, also so eine Unterstory, dass ich jetzt mal vermuten würde, viele Hörerinnen und Hörer haben das gar nicht mitbekommen.
Genau deswegen wollte ich es auch erzählen, weil ich glaube, in ganz Deutschland hat das jeder mitbekommen, dass Real Madrid da eigentlich mit Schlusspfiff das 3-2-Schoss nach Bellingham köpfte ein. Und der Schiri pfiff ab beim Moment der Flankenabgabe. Und weil es ja drei Pfiffe sind, war der erste, als die Flanke ausgeführt wird. Der zweite ist der Ball in der Luft. Der dritte ist als Bellingham köpft. Aber ich glaube, das hat man in ganz Deutschland wirklich rauf und runter gelesen und gesehen. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, die Diakabie-Story, die soll wirklich nicht unter dem Laster fallen, weil das ist eigentlich die größere Geschichte, eben im leider sehr negativen Falle für den armen Kerl. Aber ja, der andere Moment, den kann man natürlich auch diesen Schlusspfiff nennen.
Ich wollte es nämlich deswegen dazu sagen, weil die Verletzung war ja kurz vor Schluss. Und wenn man sich eben fragt, wie kam es überhaupt auch zu dieser langen Nachspielzeit und auch zu dieser Konfusion. Und ich will es nicht den Schiedsrichter in Schutz nehmen. Das war natürlich eine sehr unglückliche Situation und so weiter. Aber das fand ich schon interessant. Ich habe das dann nämlich erst dann im Nachhinein gecheckt, dass quasi beide schon so ein bisschen miteinander zusammenhängen, nämlich zeitlich. Dass es eben erst diese ganz schlimme Verletzung gibt, in der 89. Minute dann die Auswechslung und dann kommt dieses ganze Nachspielzeit.
Ja, acht Minuten Nachspielzeit und in der neunten Minute in der Nachspielzeit oder neun plus sogar, wäre eigentlich das Tor gefallen. Er hat dann abgepfiffen. Also wer längere Ausführungen dazu haben will, kann ich kleine Werbung machen im TikTok-Podcast. Da habe ich mit Nils Kehren, dem alten Badrudista natürlich etwas länger und ausführlicher darüber gesprochen. Denn es war natürlich der große, große Aufreger in der Liga. Ja, aber da wart ihr euch doch sicher einig, dass ihr völlig gerecht bei den Schwerter abpfeift. Da muss sich jeder einig sein. Ich pfeife ja selber auf ganz niedrigem Niveau ab und zu Spiele. Und man weiß ja eigentlich, um es ganz kurz nur auszuführen, als Schiedsrichter machst du dich ja angreifbar, wenn du in einer Flanke oder in einen Schuss abpfeifst, sei es zur Halbzeit oder zum Schlusspfiff. Deswegen macht man das als Schiedsrichter nicht. Also man hat doch eigentlich das Fingerspitzengefühl, dass man da nicht reinpfeift. Von daher einfach absolut unerklärlich, wie ein Profi-Schiri, der ja glaube ich auch UEFA und FIFA-Schiri ist, dass einem so ein Rookie-Mistake, dass er so einen Fehler macht, ist wirklich unerklärlich. Und wie gesagt, er hat ja Real Madrid wirklich ein Tor geklaut dadurch.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so lange darüber reden. Real wird trotzdem Meister, Jude Bellingham wird irgendwann wieder spielen. Es ist wichtig, dass Diakapi noch mal Fußball spielen kann und dass es hoffentlich auch nicht so lange dauert. Und dann haben wir auch noch einen Moment des Spieltags, vielleicht der Saison, in der Serie A. Ja, ich muss an Alex anknüpfen. Es sind zwei Momente. Also ich muss leider auch traurig anknüpfen. Domenico Mimmo Berardi hat sich am Wochenende die Achilles-Szene gerissen. Berardi Europameister von 2021, wäre logisch jetzt auch für diese EM ein Mann gewesen und spielt ja bei Sassuolo, die diese unfassbar schwierige Saison spielen, die hinten drin sind, die seit Wochen nur verlieren, die den Trainer gewechselt haben, die jetzt mittlerweile wirklich sogar Vorletzter sind. Und Berardi war so der Hoffnungsschimmer, der war davor wochenlang verletzt, kam jetzt zurück und bei seinem Comeback bei der 0-1-Niederlage gegen Hellas Achilles-Szene-Riss. Also EM aus, sowieso klar, die Prognosen gehen auch Richtung 8, 9, 10 Monate. Und wer weiß, Spinazzola zum Beispiel hat sich ja bei der EM die Achilles-Szene gerissen. Der ist leider danach nicht mehr der geworden, der davor war. Also ein ganz bitterer Moment für Berardi, für Sassuolo in der aktuellen Situation und auch für die italienische Nationalmannschaft. Aber der zweite Moment, und den müssen wir halt auch noch aufgreifen, ist Paul Pogba. Es ist jetzt seit wenigen Tagen offiziell. Die Sperre wurde bestätigt, seine Doping-Sperre. Vier Jahre hat er bekommen. Und ja, dementsprechend das Thema Karriereende ist da jetzt logisch auch ein großes Thema. Wir hatten ja schon damals gesprochen, glaube ich, es war im Herbst, als er da rauskam. Jetzt ist es einfach offiziell, ja, ganz bittere Entwicklung logischerweise. Also ich glaube, es hat einiges darauf hingedeutet, dass es in die Richtung geht. Ich glaube, es gab wenig Gründe, zumindest was man öffentlich mitbekommen hat, dass er da eine Chance hat sozusagen, das Ganze irgendwie noch zum Positiven zu wenden. Ja, und irgendwie halt auch zu Pogba, der irgendwie – ja, Michael kann das ja auch wunderbar einordnen – er hat wahnsinnig viel erreicht, aber doch vielleicht auch vieles nicht erreicht, was er eigentlich mit seinen Qualitäten hätte machen können. Alessandro Matri, Teamkollege von ihm damals bei Juve, hat dieser Tage gesprochen über ihn, und das fand ich echt sehr treffend. Er meinte, er war auch nach seiner Juve-Zeit immer mit Pogba noch in Kontakt, also als Pogba ja wieder zu United zurückgegangen ist. Und er hat gemeint, über Pogba wurde manchmal in der Öffentlichkeit ein falsches Bild gezeichnet. Er hat gesagt, so dominant und so selbstbewusst, wie er auf dem Feld immer war oder aufgetreten ist, war er abseits des Felles nicht. Und er hat erzählt, gerade diese United-Zeit hat ihm sehr zugesetzt. Da war ja Mourinho damals da und Mourinho hat es ihm nicht leicht gemacht öffentlich. Und er hat gemeint, da hat er sehr darunter gelitten, weil er ihm sehr sensibel ist. Und er hat gemeint, er weiß von Pogba, dass er zu United zurück ist und unbedingt sozusagen seinen alten Leuten wieder zeigen wollte, dass er sie mitreißt. Und das ist ihm nicht gelungen. Und bei Juve war jetzt die Geschichte ja im Prinzip ähnlich. Er kam zu Juve zurück mit riesener Wartungshaltung und konnte es da auch nicht zeigen. Und jetzt wollen wir nicht spekulieren. Brauchen wir auch nicht ins Psychologische rein. Ich weiß logisch nicht, ob das damit zu tun hat, dass es am Ende dazu kam, dass er letztes Jahr im Sommer auf der Vorbereitungstour in den USA anscheinend eben an den Juve-Ärzten vorbei zu einem Mittelgriff, das eben auf der Dopenliste war. Das will ich gar nicht bewerten, aber Fakt ist, sowohl seine zweite Zeit bei United als auch seine zweite Zeit bei Juve verlief halt alles andere als so, wie er es sich vorgestellt hat. Und wie gesagt, Matri meinte, er ist sehr sensibel, auch wenn es auf dem Feld komplett anders herumkommt. Und deswegen jetzt ein sehr, sehr trauriges Ende, würde ich mal sagen. 30 Jahre ist er jetzt alt, für vier Jahre ist er gesperrt. Er ist Weltmeister, vierfache italienischer Meister, Europa League-Sieger, die Nations League hat er gewonnen, Pokale hat er gewonnen in England und in Italien. Und dennoch wäre mehr möglich gewesen, das allein zeigt schon, was für ein Spieler Paul Pogba wahrscheinlich war, muss man sagen. Am 14. September in der Sendung haben wir darüber geredet. Ich werde es auch noch mal verlinken, die Hintergründe, die du ja auch kurz angerissen hast. Noch mal kurz angesprochen.
In vier Jahren unterscheidet der Bereich Etappe, was ich schon sehe, wenn er wieder zurückgeht. Die geben gerne dem einen oder anderen eine zweite Chance, der zwielichtige Hintergründe hat.
In vier Jahren wird es die Ligatour immer noch geben. Wahrscheinlich werden wir uns dann mit Hologrammen sogar nebeneinander sitzen auf einer Wettendascount. Dann wird uns das Fabian sicherlich mitbringen als Moment der Saison. Wir werden darüber reden. Da freue ich mich schon drauf. Ihr drei. Das hat mir eine sehr große Freude gemacht. Ich muss noch mal kurz durchzählen. Uli Hebel, da hören wir gleich noch. Herzlichen Dank an Alex Treuker. Danke, dass du wieder mit dabei warst.
Sehr gerne, sehr gerne.
Und sehr schön, Michael Postel, dass du es mal geschafft hast. Schön, dass du hier warst.
Darf ich abschließend noch einen Querverweis einbauen, Max?
Natürlich, logisch.
Wer nicht genug von Christian und mir hat, es gibt beim Tikitaka Podcast auch einen YouTube-Kanal. Und Christian und ich werden mit dem Kollegen Nils Kern natürlich am Sonntag voraussichtlich eine kleine Special-Folge aufnehmen. Also, wer da Bock drauf hat, mehr von Christian und mir zu hören, der sei gespannt und abonniere den YouTube-Kanal vom Tikitaka Podcast sehr gerne. Wartet da was auf euch.
Heißt das, ich darf jetzt auch sagen, dass alle den Kicker lesen sollen?
Das, äh… Montag und Donnerstag, Leute.
Also, lesen alle den Kicker, schaut alle da sauen, hört den Tikitaka Podcast, abonniert alle Gäste überall, wo sie nur verfügbar sind und wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr auch noch einen Rasenfunk hören. Was ihr aber definitiv macht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ist jetzt dranbleiben, denn jetzt geht's weiter mit Uli Hebel. Uli Hebel ist jetzt da. Uli, ich freu mich. Schön, dass du's geschafft hast.
Grüß dich. Ich freu mich auch.
Tausend Moderationjobs, so muss man sagen, ey, das ist schon cool, dass du die Ligatour da noch reinquetschst. Vielen Dank dafür. Und du hast auch wieder zwei Themen mitgebracht, mit was möchtest du starten, mit dem etwas positiveren oder dem etwas negativeren?
Ich würde mal sagen, wir fangen mit dem negativen anderen was weg, oder?
Ja, machen wir das auch die Fans des betroffenen Vereins. Also liebe Manchester United-Fans, ihr müsst jetzt stark bleiben. Warum? Was ist denn los bei United? Also 44 Punkte, Rang 6, klar, das ist nicht ganz so gut, wie es dem Anspruch entspricht, aber dem Anspruch läuft mir ja schon mehrere Jahre jetzt hinterher. Was ist das Problem, Uli?
Also ich mache es gleich teilpositiv, dann ist es nicht ganz so schlimm, glaube ich, zu hören. Die Ergebnisse sind okay, das jetzt gegen Manchester City am Wochenende nichts ging, ist, glaube ich, eingermaßen eingepreist. Inzwischen, das muss man immer dazu sagen, das wäre früher fürchterlich gewesen, so was überhaupt zu sagen, im Kontext Manchester United, dass das eingermaßen okay wäre zu verlieren. Aber ich glaube, das ist inzwischen fast schon normal. Ansonsten sind die Ergebnisse okay. Was positiv ist, ist die Defensive. Also alles, was bei Ten Hag gegen den Ball läuft, da bin ich eingermaßen einverstanden damit. Es gibt dann ein, zwei, drei Sachen, die mir nicht so gut gefallen, aber alles in allem ist es okay. Mit dem Ball ist es wie zu aller Schlimmsten Ole Gunnar Solskjaer-Zeiten.
Ehrlich?
Jaja, also sie verlassen sich komplett auf Einzelaktionen und oder Konter. Mehr ist nicht drin. Dann sind sie auch nicht schlecht, wenn sie das machen. Aber das ist mir bedeutend zu wenig im Moment.
Das hätte ich ehrlich gesagt von Ten Hag so nicht erwartet. Da hat doch eine Transformation stattgefunden in den letzten Jahren.
Ja, also ich muss jetzt mal mir die Zeitlinie vor Augen führen. Also es war so, dass er zu Beginn der letzten Saison, es war dann sein erstes Jahr, das fühlt sich für mich schon wieder wie zehn Jahre, aber weil ich schon so, so viel darüber gesprochen habe und immer wieder die verschiedenen Umbauten mitgemacht habe. Also zu Beginn der Saison wollte er recht aggressiv spielen gegen den Ball und wollte auch einfach eher Ballbesitz orientiert und etwas riskanter, sage ich jetzt mal, am Ball. Das hat er aber dann nach zwei Spielen schon holen müssen, weil sie da ja zweimal so hoch verloren haben, gleich zu Beginn der Saison. Ein enormes Sicherheitssystem eingebaut. Das war dann gut, ergebnistechnisch gut. Es war halt so, wir haben am Stück 1-0 gewonnen und 2-1 und so. Und dann irgendwann hat er es nochmal etwas geöffnet hinten raus in der Saison, um es dann zum Schluss wieder komplett einzupressen. Und in dieser Saison sind sie eigentlich überhaupt nie reingekommen mit Spiel am Ball. Es ist jetzt nicht nur ein Ten-Haach-Thema, muss man auch ehrlich sagen, sondern lag an der Fitness der einzelnen Leute, die einfach nicht da waren. 2, 3, 4, 5 Themen rundherum, für die er überhaupt nichts kann, dass Anthony sich einfach wie ein Vollarschloch, sorry, aber ist ja so benommen hat und dann die Jaden-Sensual-Geschichte etc. etc. Und das führte auch irgendwann dazu, plus eben auch wieder Fitnessprobleme, dass er dann einfach ein Sicherheitssystem eingezogen hat. Und da sind wir jetzt und das geht jetzt so circa seit zwei Monaten. Ich sag immer, ich finde, er kontrolliert, was er kontrollieren kann, Ten-Haach. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das genügend ist an Prozess, an positiven Prozess für ein zweites Jahr bei Manchester United. Das ist auch nicht das erste Mal, auch das muss man dazu sagen, dass ein Trainer nach Alex Ferguson, insbesondere in der zweiten Saison, dann so richtig abstürzt, in Anführungszeichen. Aber wir kommen ja sicherlich auch gleich noch drauf. Sie haben sich ja ein bisschen was getan im Board bei United und das könnte dann schon sein, dass das irgendwann mal ten Hag zum Verhängnis wird, weil ich eben nicht glaube, dass das den Leuten, die da das sagen haben, genügt, weil man sich ja an sich tendenziell eher verschlechtert als verbessert in der laufenden Saison jetzt. Und das Geld ist ja trotzdem drin in dem Verein, so ist es ja nicht.
Ja und vor allem, es gibt halt keinen Mittelweg bei United. 14 Siege, zwei unentschieden, aber 11 Niederlagen. Das ist halt nach 27 Spielen einfach viel, viel, viel zu viel. Eigentlich musst du da dankbar für sein, dass du da noch 6er sein kannst. Das hat auch damit zu tun, dass eben im Mittelfeld der Premier League es wenige gibt, die so richtig mal längerfristige Serien haben starten können. Weil irgendwann kommt immer einer aus den Top 4 und gegen den verlierst du halt dann. Genau. Das ist das Problem. Aber dann lass doch mal kurz über das, was neben dem Feld passiert ist sprechen. Denn ich hatte das Gefühl, das hat schon für eine kleinere Euphorie zumindest gesorgt, dass eben mit Jim Redcliffe ein neuer Miteigentümer ins Board gekommen ist.
Ja, also auch da muss man jetzt wieder einordnend sagen, ganz gleich, wer den Glaciers-Anteile abnimmt, das würde als positiv gesehen werden, weil echt viel schlimmer geht es nicht. Also, mir würden noch zwei, drei Individuen einfallen, aber die haben mit Fußball nichts zu tun. Deswegen, das ist erst mal positiv. Und ja, haben einen neuen CEO installiert, nachdem die beiden davor, Woodward und dessen Kumpel, das war ja eigentlich nie eine Renovierung auf der Position, das war einfach nur Woodward's Studienkumpel Richard Arnold, die übernommen haben, die einfach nichts mit Fußball zu tun haben, die reine Banker waren und die einfach auch nie getan haben, was man bei Manchester United hätte tun müssen. Also die gar nie so angepackt haben, wie sie es hätten tun müssen. Jetzt kommt jemand von Manchester City, der einen Riesenruf genießt auf der Insel, vorher auch schon für Barcelona und vor allen Dingen in das dortige Marketing verantwortlich war in der Guardiola-Zeit. Das heißt, das scheint jemand zu sein, der sie wirklich weiterbringt. Auch auf anderen Positionen räumen sie auf. Dafür ist Jim Radcliffe bekannt, der reiste Mann Englands, der nicht lange wartet. Wenn er nicht überzeugt ist von jemandem, dann so sagt man zumindest, räumt er recht schnell auf. Ich kenne ihn jetzt aus England auch nicht besonders gut, der ist in Nizza auch noch. Da weiß man, dass der die Leute holt, denen er vertraut. Das finde ich jetzt aber erst mal gar nicht so schlecht, weil da ist über all die Jahre es sich gemütlich gemacht worden und sehr, sehr, sehr viel Amigo-Wirtschaft betrieben worden im Verein selbst. Der ist halt immer noch gut genug aufgestellt, sodass das nie großartig auffühlt, weil der Verein international so beliebt ist, dass die Absätze und sowas immer da sind, selbst wenn es eben nicht mehr – das hat man ja früher immer befürchtet – selbst wenn es eben nicht mehr regelmäßig für Champions League-Wussball reicht. Aber, dass da jetzt so was passiert, ist gut. Sie sind jetzt auch ein Director of Football. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt sogar schon durch ist, aber da hatten sie auch einen dran, der einen sehr hohen großen Ruf genießt auf der Insel, der sowohl im Jugendbereich als auch im Profibereich, als auch im Übergangsbereich, große Arbeit geleistet hat. Deswegen bin ich da jetzt erst mal positiv. Karn aber eben auch zur Folge haben – und das hört, liest man auch schon – dass Red Cliff ein großer Sidan-Fan sein soll, dass der überlegt, sozusagen den auch abzulösen, würde er Sidan bekommen. Jetzt erst mal konjunktiv, aber kann man sich.
Irgendwie schon vorstellen, dass Sidan vielleicht sagt, na ja, es ist ja ganz okay. Aber das sind ja eh alles Spekulationen. Aber kannst du uns nochmal kurz erklären, wie jetzt dann die Eigentümerstruktur ist? Weil die Glaciers sind ja noch drin, Jim Radcliffe ist mit dazu gekommen. Warum werden jetzt dann trotzdem so viele Prozesse angestoßen, obwohl er ja Minderheiten-Eigentümer ist? Ist es weil da auch, also weil die Glaciers froh sind, dass es jetzt jemand macht, weil das quasi Teil seines Einstiegs war? Was ist da eigentlich passiert?
Also die Glaciers haben ja nie großartig Interesse gehabt an dem Verein. Das war ja immer nur ein Vehikel, um Geld rauszuziehen, sozusagen. Und Jim Redcliffe ist quasi eines Vermögens, sozusagen immer jemand gewesen, der Spaß dran hatte, mit seinem Geld im Fußball was zu bewegen. Und deswegen versucht der so viel zu bewegen, sozusagen. Also der hat ja grundsätzlich jetzt erstmal nur – auch da muss man mal vorsichtig sein – aber bis zu 25 Prozent. Ich habe noch nie von genau 25 Prozent gelesen. Weiß ich allerdings auch nicht, das ist auch gar nicht so leicht. Und diese Einios, die ja sozusagen dann die Gruppe ist, die United dann über Jim Redcliffe, der ist halt nur das Gesicht, wie in allen englischen – oder nicht in allen, aber in den allermeisten – Konveraten dann sozusagen der Fall ist. Und der Grund ist einfach das, dass Redcliffe sich – also sagt man zumindest – auch da, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, der würde sich schon vorstellen können, Mehrheitseigner bei United zu werden, also mindestens 51 Prozent zu haben. Und man geht auch davon aus, dass die Glaciers irgendwann einmal bereit wären, komplett zu verkaufen. Das war ja durchaus schon, also bevor dieser Deal jetzt über die Bühne ging, war davon auch schon immer zu lesen. Es ging ja ewig lang, diese Übernahme, und da war schon auch davon zu lesen, dass eventuell die Glaciers sogar komplett alles abgeben würden. Das ist die große Frage, tun sie es, tun sie es noch, was müsste passieren, dass sie es tun? Die sprechen ja nicht, man weiß ja nie ganz genau, was sozusagen die Idee hinter dem ist, aber ich würde mal tippen, dass die jetzt erstmal warten. Es gibt auch wiederum Berichte, auch da weiß ich aber nicht, ob das stimmt, dass Red Cliff seine Anteile erhöhen könnte, also Abraham und Joel Glaser, die ja dann als Jungs sozusagen übernommen haben, sollen angeblich den Deal gemacht haben, dass die Möglichkeit sogar gibt, dass Red Cliff das Ganze erhöhen könnte, aber das müsste dann wiederum die Premier League genehmigen etc. etc. Das ist alles ein bisschen schwierig und wie immer, wenn die Gläser so involviert sind, nie transparent. Du weißt halt nie ganz genau, was ist überhaupt das Interesse dahinter. Man hat sich ja lange gefragt, was überhaupt deren Interesse ist, Manchester United zu haben, zu besitzen. Man glaubt das jetzt zu wissen, nämlich dass man sagt, ok gut, solange das Marketinggeschäft mit United funktioniert, dann können sie halt Geld rausziehen. Sie haben sich ja dann auch Anleihen überschrieben, sodass sie dann wiederum sich selbst Miete bezahlen etc. etc. Da kannst du schon mal Geld rausziehen, aber warum sie es zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt noch halten, ist die große Frage. Vielleicht ist es aber auch nur eine Frage des Angebots. Ich habe das noch nicht so ganz herausfinden können. Mir hat es auch der Kollege aus England, der in der Regel ganz gut vernetzt ist im Verein. Mit ihm habe ich auch über diese ganze Übernahmenthemen gesprochen. Red Cliff ist wohl auch grundsätzlich etwas, wie soll man sagen, etwas medienfreundlicher. Der gibt hier und da mal so einen Hintergrund. Bei den Glazes war da gar nicht dran zu denken. Die haben die nie zu Gesicht bekommen. Selbst die Beat-Writer da nicht. Es bleibt spannend, wie hoch das Wirken von Red Cliff auch ist. Es mag natürlich auch sein, dass das nur so rüberkommt, dass der so viel Einfluss genießt, eben weil er durchaus mal das Gespräch sucht mit dem My Runner Medien Vertreter und man dann das Gefühl hat, da packt jetzt wieder jemand an. Ob es dann letztlich so ist, weiß ich nicht. Also nenne mal das Beispiel bei Jersey, haben wir auch schon hier drüber geredet. In Deutschland denkt immer noch jeder Todd Bolli ist der starke Mann. Ist nicht der Fall. Aber um das rauszufinden, da habe ich erst mal ganz schön lang telefonieren müssen und selber mal vor Ort sein müssen, um zu sehen, wer verhält sich denn wie. Also Bolli ist derjenige, der die Hände schüttelt, aber die Geschäfte, die macht währenddessen, Beda Degbali. Das heißt, das wird jetzt ein bisschen dauern, einfach rauszufinden, wer was wie wo.
Ach, es ist schon faszinierend, was für andere Themen das sind. Und sehr wahrscheinlich nach dem, was ich gelesen habe, es gab ja so einen richtigen Run, vor allem von US-Investoren auf Premier League-Vereine und der wurde je gestoppt, als die Zinsen so nach oben gegangen sind. Und in dieser Phase hinein hieß es dann auch erstmals, dass vielleicht doch nur Teile verkauft werden von United. Also vielleicht war es sogar die hohen Zinsen, die das gestoppt haben und dann...
Möglich, ja.
Wer weiß es schon. Ist ja auch für uns zwei jetzt auch nicht so relevant. Wir berichten nur drüber und wir müssen halt das sehen, was Manchester United spielt und das ist nicht immer schön. Anders ist es aber beim anderen Team, über das wir sprechen wollen. Und ich gebe es zu, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich musste Uli ein bisschen dazu drängen, dass wir jetzt über Arsenal sprechen können, denn er möchte immer nicht die offensichtlichen Teams nehmen. Das weiß ich auch sehr zu schätzen. Aber nachdem die jetzt sechs Spiele in Folge gewonnen haben, nachdem die Platz 1, 2, 3, Liverpool City und Arsenal haben 63, 62 und 61 Punkte, alle gleich viele Spiele. Also da muss ich jetzt über einen von diesen drei sprechen. Und nachdem wir Liverpool schon öfter hatten und City schon öfter haben und die beiden jetzt ja auch gegeneinander spielen, lass uns über Arsenal sprechen. Was ist bei Arsenal los, dass man diesen kurzen Wackler, den man ja in der Saison schon drin hatte, jetzt so ausgleichen konnte und oben dranbleiben?
Auch da, Dubai ist los gewesen. Aber hat in dem Fall nichts mit den Besitzverhältnissen zu tun, sondern in dieser sogenannten Player Break, die als eingebaut wurde, also eine Pseudowinterpause in England, war Arsenal im Trainingslager in Dubai. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es eine Aussprache gebraucht hätte, aber man soll sich zunächst sehr, sehr deutlich die Meinung gesagt haben untereinander. Und Ateta hat davon berichtet, dass er an vielen, vielen Details hat arbeiten können, die einfach so nicht mehr möglich waren im Laufe der Saison. Und so vom Gefühl her war es ein leichter Reset. Man muss es dazu sagen, Arsenal war zu keinem Zeitpunkt in der Saison, ich meine wirklich zu keinem, schwach oder schlecht oder auch nur in der Nähe von schlecht. Die waren in jedem einzelnen Spiel. Also alle, die ich aufgezeichnet habe, und zwei oder drei muss ich halt nachgucken, aber alle, die ich aufgezeichnet habe, hätte ich gesagt, der Plan war der bessere als der vom Gegner. Sie waren in der Regel das bessere Team, was die Spielanteile betrifft, und sie haben sich auch durchaus mehr Chancen rausgespielt. In der Qualität der Chancen kann man dann drüber sprechen und vor allen Dingen über den Abschluss, und das ist dann fast eskaliert. Das war dann so das FA Cup-Spiel gegen – boah, das ist jetzt nicht falsch, aber ich glaube, Liverpool war es. Ja, und da haben sie wirklich erste Hälfte Liverpool dominiert. Das muss man genauso sagen, verlieren das Spiel aber trotzdem, weil einfach Havertz alleine sechs Großchancen vergibt. Und das war eben auch Thema in Dubai. Und seit sie da wieder zurück sind, wirken sie frischer. Ich finde, das Gefühl ist nicht mehr so sehr, das haben sie ja letztes Jahr um diese Zeit bekommen, dass man dachte, okay, jetzt merken die es selbst. Wir sind kurz davor, was ganz Großes zu erreichen, und dann geht so die Leichtigkeit weg und du zwingst dich rein in das Ganze. Und das ist irgendwie, seid ihr wieder weg, sondern ich habe das Gefühl, die wissen selbst, wir können nur gewinnen. Aber, Klammer auf, die Ausnahme ist die Champions League und deswegen macht es es so schwer, den Leuten das zu erklären, weil es gegen Porto genau wieder dieses Gefühl gab. Da sind sie sehr, sehr viel besser, das ganze Spiel über. Dann kriegen sie hinten raus einen Kunstschuss und dann steht es halt 1-0 für Porto. In Porto auch nichts Dramatisches. Ich würde denen auch jederzeit zutrauen, dass sie das im Rückspiel lösen. Aber man merkt schon noch, sobald die Stufe nach oben geht und die ganze Welt auf Arsene guckt, dann kriegen sie leichte Probleme. Aber, und Klick & Rush-Hörerinnen und Hörer, die fangen jetzt an zu trinken, weil sie das Trinkspiel schon parat haben, ich sage das immer und immer wieder, und das ist aber auch ganz wichtig, dieser Kern hat das allererste Champions League K.o.-Spiel zusammen absolviert. Das ist immer noch mit das jüngste Team, egal wie du es rechnest, statt Formation sind sie es nicht, im Kader sind sie es dann wieder, dann haben sie es teilweise wieder, was die eingesetzten Spieler betrifft, im Durchschnittsalter, immer noch eins der zwei, drei jüngsten Teams der Liga. Und das darf man einfach nie vergessen, sie sind einfach total weit vor ihren eigenen Planen, Zeitplänen vor allen Dingen. Und deshalb bin ich trotzdem, und wenn man sich in der Premier League das anschaut, gestern Benny Grund, der ist ja auch Freude des Hauses hier, der hat mir nur geschrieben, ich habe das Sheffield-Spiel vom Montag nachgeguckt, das ist ja Wahnsinn, was die abreißen. Na, ich sag, siehste, sag ich dir doch die ganze Zeit, das ist echt nah dran an Perfektion, wenn ich finde. Also gerade gegen die kleinen Gegner haben sie inzwischen Mittel und Wege gefunden, da ist auch Kai Havertz nicht ganz unwichtig, da gefallen die mir ausgezeichnet.
Wir haben allein in drei Auswärtsspielen zweimal 6 zu 0 und einmal 5 zu 0 gewonnen, in West Ham gegen Burnley und bei Sheffield United.
Also gegen Burnley können wir zwar jetzt auch gerade, aber gegen West Ham ist das insbesondere auch nach Standard-Situationen, das ist ein Team, das dir Standards hinzaubert, hast du nicht gesehen. Das ist wirklich das Beste, was Europa zu bieten hat. Da gibt es ein paar in der Premier League, die das echt sehr, sehr gut machen. Aber das ist derart variantenreich. Auch da wieder ein Minusport oder was, furchtbar. Aber ansonsten ist es derart variantenreich. Und die haben West Ham einfach mal damit schnell geschlagen. Und 6 zu 0 gegen West Ham, mein Bruder hat das Spiel damals gemacht, das musste ich nachgucken, weil ich es nicht live sehen konnte. Da hat er mir nur geschrieben, das glaubst du nicht, die führen gerade 4-0 nach 20 Minuten gegen West Ham. Da habe ich gesagt, ja, es ist einfach jeder Standard wird drin.
Das ist faszinierend. Und glaubst du, dass Arsenal vielleicht auch davon profitieren kann, dass sich alles dann doch irgendwie um Liverpool und City dreht aktuell? Also ich meine, klar ist immer Manchester City der Favorit auf dem Premier League Titel. Und wir haben bei Liverpool natürlich die große Klopp-Geschichte. Könnte das jetzt mit der Titel sein? Wenn man irgendwie unbemerkt zum Titel sich sneaken will, dann ja doch in so einer Konstellation. Hättest du das für möglich oder wie viel Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit würdest du dem geben?
Also normalerweise würden wir sagen, wir haben drei Kampf, deswegen 33 so ungefähr. Aber ich hab die schon als Außenseiter und das erhöht aber in der Zeit gleich auch wieder die Chancen. Also ich glaub, die anderen beiden sind noch ein Ticken, wie soll man sagen, also erstens länger dabei. Das ist glaube ich nicht ganz unwichtig in dem Prozess. Aber ich hab immer vor der Saison auch gesagt und das Ranking verändert sich auch gar nicht großartig. City o City, die sind, wie du sagst, Topfavorit. Arsenal hab ich als zweites Team tatsächlich und bei Liverpool muss alles ideal laufen und es tut es in den allermeisten Fällen in der Saison. Dann könnten die Arsenal den zweiten Platz streitig machen und genauso würde ich auch gehen, wobei ich Arsenal mindestens auf Augenhöhe mit Liverpool hab. Nicht ganz mit City, ehrlicherweise, aber mindestens auf Augenhöhe mit Liverpool hab. Das heißt, ich trau das denen schon zu. Ich weiß halt nur nicht, ob ich City zutraue, dass ich es ihnen nicht zutrauen sollte. Das ist das große Problem. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich verneinen.
Ja, okay, okay, ich verstehe dich. Aber man muss sagen, die Momentaufnahme ist ganz fantastisch. Arsenal hat den besten Sturm aktuell, 68 Tore und die beste Abwehrderliga mit 23 Gegentoren. Also das ist schon sehr, sehr, sehr stabil. Uli, dann haben wir noch unsere Awards. MVP, Anshang Hero und Moment des Spieltags. Wen magst du denn als MVP ins Rennen schicken?
Da mache ich es mir jetzt auch. Also heute machen wir einfach die Big Six Edition, würde ich sagen. Dann mache ich es mir jetzt mal ganz einfach.
Das finde ich gut. Ich komme hier erst mal mit Fulham und dann überzeuge ich ihn. Dann sagt er das auch.
Ich nehme das einfach bei Anshang Hero, haue ich Fulham rein. Könnte ich sogar wirklich machen, muss ich vielleicht nur mal überlegen, ob ich das umswitche. Also MVP, Honorable Mention an Oli Watkins, der seine Produktivsaison spielt und damit die Effizienz Aston Villas ist, da vorne drin. Ein dicker Grund dafür. Aber im Moment muss man glaube ich Phil Foden nennen. Das ist nicht nur, weil Guardiola sagt, er ist der beste Spieler der Premier League, sondern ich habe das jetzt über die letzten Wochen auch immer mal wieder zu thematisieren versucht, warum das gerade so funktioniert bei ihm. Und ich glaube, dass ein Umdenken stattgefunden hat. Man dachte bei Phil Foden, das muss aus der Breite der Spielmacher sein. Und das ist er einfach gar nicht. Sondern das ist jemand, den gibst du den Ball in den Fuß. Weil es ist erstaunlich, wie der den Ball verarbeitet. Der erste Kontakt ist eine Sensation. Und was der dann macht, also wie er dreht und sowas, das ist einfach, das sucht seinesgleichen. Und inzwischen ist er mehr positioniert als der Ballempfänger und Abschlussspieler. Und seitdem er das ist, ist er sehr, sehr viel besser und wirklich extrem wichtig. Es ist erstaunlich, dass sich bei City Jahr für Jahr dann einer herausarbeitet, der unter den De Bruyne sind, Harlands und Rodries und Bernados, von denen er eh weiß, die sind eh anderswie zu berücksichtigen. Gibt es immer einen, der sich noch mal eine Stufe nach oben korrigiert. Letztes Jahr war es Grealish, von dem niemand dachte, dass er das sein könnte und in dem Jahr ist es Phil Foden, der jetzt nicht mehr endlich nur dieses Riesentalent ist, sondern wirklich ein absoluter Spielegewinner inzwischen ist und das er auch gegen United so gemacht hat. Deswegen glaube ich, da musste ich am wenigsten lange nachdenken darüber, sondern das ist zu klar im Moment. Es wird auch jetzt für das Liverpool-Spiel am Wochenende derjenige sein, um den sich alles dreht.
28 Torbeteilungen in 40 Pflichtspielen, allein 11 Tore und 7 Assists in der Liga. Und wer irgendwas von diesem United-Spiel mitbekommen hat vom Wochenende, der war jetzt nicht überrascht, als du Phil Foden genannt hast. Ich denke, so kann man es formulieren. Jetzt habe ich dir noch ein bisschen Zeit gegeben, darüber nachzudenken. Wer ist denn jetzt dein Handsong-Hero?
Dann mache ich jetzt mal was anderes. Ich hatte ursprünglich was anderes vor, aber dann habe ich voll mit drin, so wie ich es ursprünglich geplant hatte. Ich nehme Tossin Adrabayo. Manchmal ist es ja so, dass der ein Spieler erst dann richtig fehlt oder es auffällt, dass er dir fehlt, wenn er eben nicht dabei ist. Und wenn er dann dabei ist, merkst du, okay, da läuft was. Und das sind jetzt gar nicht so die, du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, okay, mit dem spiele ich dann plötzlich Tiki-Taka-Fußball oder so. Das ist nicht der Fall. Aber sie sind bei Vollem wesentlich sicherer, wenn der auf dem Platz steht, beim Auslösen von hinten raus, kommen noch besser durchs Pressing. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass sie immer eine andere Staffelung haben, wenn der dabei ist. Und mit dem, als der zurückkam, ging es auch los, dass sie ihren ersten Run in der Saison richtig hatten. Also sprich im Dezember müsste das wahrscheinlich gewesen sein, als es die Paar fünf zu irgendwas gegeben hatte. Und kann man auch letztlich daran ablesen, der ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz jung, der müsste jetzt 5 oder 26 sein, aber Vertrag läuft aus. Und so ziemlich die halbe Welt ist hinter dem her. Also es gibt nicht so wenige, bei Meilen, da weisen wir uns eh das Thema gerne in die Premier League schauen, bei ablösefreien Spielern, die sollen wohl dran sein. Dann hätte es auch schon zwei, drei gegeben, die im Winter schon Ablöse noch für ihn bezahlt hätten. Aber auch bei City, ausgebildet in der Academy, auch Arsenal soll Interesse haben. Auch City soll durchaus wieder überlegen, ob sie den nicht ablösefrei verpflichten würden. Weil großgewachsen kein Weltklasse-Fußballer war ordentlich. Natürlich gut in der Luft. Das muss man glaube ich bei 1, 96 Körpergröße nicht dazu sagen. Und so als Typ, alles was ich auch so aus dem Umfeld höre, muss der wahnsinnig wichtig sein. Deswegen ist das vielleicht sogar die Definition eines Anssang Heroes.
Aber wirklich, wenn du das jetzt nicht gerade den Nagel auf den Kopf getroffen hast, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Bleibt nur noch die Frage nach dem Moment des Spieltags, Oli.
Ja, ich habe überlegt, ob es der Spieltag sein muss oder vielleicht sogar das Wochenende davor, als Liverpool den EFL Cup geholt hat und man dann merkt bei Jürgen Klopp. Aber einfach der Spirit, den Liverpool in dieser Saison hat, den merkt man auch noch ganz gut vom letzten Spieltag, als sie in 99, also plus, 9 plus, so, 90 plus 9, so ist es richtig, als sie den Siegtreffer machen von David Nunes. Ich war schon bereit für mein Spiel, hab das nur noch so geguckt und hab dem Kumpel nur geschrieben, ja, jetzt geht's los, 0-0. Und dann hab ich ihm parallel noch telefoniert und ich hab das Spiel noch fertig geguckt und dann lege ich auf und dann ist 1-0 Liverpool. Und eigentlich, ich bin so doof, dass ich gezweifelt habe, weil es war klar, dass die Nottingham Forests noch einen einschenken würden und das ist im Moment der Geist von Liverpool. Ich glaube, die denken gar nicht mehr dran, dass sie es mal nicht gewinnen könnten und das tragen sie wirklich über den Platz und das ist in dieser Saison besonders. Das war von Anfang an zu spüren, finde ich, dass da etwas ganz Besonderes in der Truppe ist. Und wie dann Van Dijk noch, da gab es ja ein paar Kontroversen rundherum, aber wie Van Dijk dann noch so nonchalant lächelt zum Schiedsrichter geht und so. Das ist so eine positive Arroganz, die die ausstrahlen und das war schon noch mal so ein einfach ein cooler Moment. Das ist ja letztlich die Essenz von allem. Also Last-Minute-Siegtreffer und wenn es dann am Stück passiert, dann weiß man irgendwann, da ist was besonders unterwegs. Deswegen weiß ich auch nicht, ob ich Liverpool abschreiben soll. Das würde ich nie tun. Und jetzt am Sonntag dann Anfield gegen City, ein letztes Mal. Ja, könnte schon auch einen anderen Ausgang kriegen.
Aber absolut. Also ich habe die, weiß nicht mehr genau, auf welchen Zeitraum sich die Statistik bezog. Ich glaube seit 2010 Treffer in der Nachspielzeit Liverpool 44, der zweitplatzierte in der Premier League 25. Und das müsste dann schon bei City oder so gewesen sein. Also unglaublich. Und auch bei Einwechsespielern Liverpool, also bei Toren von Einwechsespielern ganz weit vorne. Und dann, also da müssen wir aber noch zwei, drei Takte zu diesem EFL Cup-Finale sagen, wo Jacy, Liverpool ja wirklich, es war ein Spiel auf Augenhohe, beide hatten Chancen. Kölner macht ein wahnsinniges Spiel bei Liverpool, ist im Grunde der MVP dieser Partie. Und mit jeder Auswechslung wird dieser Kader von Liverpool jünger. Man muss immer mehr die Spieler googeln, weil es halt irgendwelche Academy-Spieler sind. Und bei Jacy kommt halt noch der nächste Christopher Nkunku kommt rein oder Moodrae kommt rein und so weiter. Ich gefühlt steht da quasi eine Milliarde Transferwert gegen halt eine Bubimannschaft, die jetzt nicht respektierlich gemeint. Und Liverpool gewinnt dieses Spiel. Ich fand, das war also in der wirklich ereignisreichen Karriere von Jürgen Klopp. Und er selbst hat ja danach gesagt, es sei der tollste Titel für ihn gewesen. Ich glaube, an diesem einen Spiel wird man nicht vorbeikommen, weil da dem Gefühl nach, glaube ich, könnte man über dieses Spiel schreiben und daraus die komplette Karriere und das Wirken von Jürgen Klopp erklären, dass das möglich war, diesen Cup zu gewinnen, oder?
Das ist ein Kulturthema, Chelsea hat keine und das bleibt für immer das Argument der Argumente, wenn ich über Chelsea sprechen muss, solange die ihren Scheiß nicht aufräumen in diesem Verein und nicht endlich mal alle wissen, wo sie hinwollen, inklusive Trainer, der auch tausendmal umfällt im Verlaufe eines Spiels, dann wird es nichts. Und Pochettino ist aber auch nur das schwächste Glied, weil da ist so viel los in diesem Verein. Ich habe jetzt bei Chelsea wirklich außerordentlich gut vernetzt und mir haben ganz, ganz viele Mitarbeiter auch gesagt, du glaubst nicht, was abgeht. Du glaubst einfach nicht. Das ist total warmwitzig, was da passiert zum Teil. Und bei Liverpool auf der anderen Seite folgt halt alles dem einen Kommando und das seit Jahren. Und das ist genau das, was Liverpool vorangebracht hat. Die haben eine Kultur da reinzementiert von eben, wir können das schaffen. Und es ist auch ganz gleich, wer da auf dem Platz steht. Und wenn es halt die halbe Eilung ist, dann ist es halt die halbe Eilung. Macht dir nichts. Conor Bradley ist so ein Beispiel. Trent Alexander-Arnold fällt im Dezember, Januar aus und alle denken um Gottes Willen. Dann fällt Rechtsverteidiger Nummer 2 aus und alle denken um Himmelswillen. Und jetzt ist gar keiner mehr da. Und dann muss Joe Gomez überall hin rotieren und Robertson ist ja auch noch weg zu dem Teil. Dann holen sie einen zurück aus Schottland, von dem sie denken, er ist ein bisschen erfahrener. Und dann kommt Conor Bradley und du denkst dir, ok, wo haben sie eigentlich den die ganze Zeit versteckt? Weil, kein Problem. Der hat, liefert Output, problemlos und eine Energie, dass du dich fast hinknien willst. Und dann musst du dir fast wieder überlegen, eigentlich schade, dass er einen der wahrscheinlich zwei besten Rechtsverteidiger in der Premier League-Geschichte vor sich hat. Weil ansonsten wäre es klar, dann wäre das halt einfach der Andy Robertson auf rechts, weil er genau derselbe Mensch ist, der einfach den kannst du, glaube ich, im Wecker stellen, nachts um 5 und der zieht dir die Bahnen in den Vollsprint durch. Und das ist Liverpool und Chelsea versucht, sich halt irgendwas zusammen zu kaufen ohne Sinn und Verstand und wundern sich, dass nichts kleben bleibt. Ich bin auch ganz froh, aber muss ich sagen, dass Chelsea das Ding nicht gewonnen hat, muss man auch ehrlich dazu sagen, weil hätten sie es gewonnen und da haben sie sich ja alle hingelegt bei Chelsea, dass es ja wichtig wäre und es wäre für den Prozess wichtiger, als alles andere, die es in der FL Cup jetzt zu gewinnen und bla bla bla. Deswegen bin ich ganz froh, dass das dann brach liegt, weil vielleicht sich ja dann doch mal irgendwann die handelnden Personen da sagen, so können wir es jetzt nicht weiterziehen. Sehr traurig, was wäre ein Verfall bei Chelsea stattfinden, ist ja wirklich traurig.
Wirklich, wirklich wahr. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es halt auch die Wohlfühlgeschichte aus Liverpooler Sicht. Wenn du jetzt nicht ein krasser Liverpool-Hasser bist, die gibt es natürlich auch da draußen. Aber diesen Erfolg nicht zu gönnen, auch im Zustand zu kommen mit dem Tor dann in der 118. Minute, mit den Bildern danach. Ich denke, das werden ganz viele gesehen haben. Es war was ganz Besonderes. Und wer weiß, ob es nur der Auftakt von einer wirklich geschichtsträchtigen Liverpooler Saison ist. Wir werden es dann sehen. Uli, vielen, vielen Dank dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk. Es war wie immer eine große Freude. Danke dir. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich auch für eure Aufmerksamkeit und dass ihr den Rasenfunk unterstützt unter rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und ihr könnt uns auch den Kiosk gerne leer kaufen, denn da gibt es gerade 30 Prozent auf alles, bis alles weg ist. Das ist tatsächlich der Plan. In dieser Folge möchte ich danken Chris, Lara, Jan, Hightower Germany, Lars P und Erik. Sie alle haben uns zuletzt unterstützt. Vielen Dank dafür. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, bleibt gesund.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.